uh james in practical terms uh what does
it mean for the people of scotland
moving from stage two to stage three
that means quite a lot there was quite a
lot in there out on that shift from two
to three
and indeed scotland's first minister
described it
as the most significant step in the
easing
of scotland's lockdown there is a lot in
there as i say i'll skim through
some of it in terms of people getting
back together
socializing there was good news 15
people
from five different households can now
get together
outdoors at a distance of two meters and
in terms of indoors
eight people from three different
households can
socialize within the same building and
that can include
overnight stays but nicolas sturgeon
stressed that
there is a big much bigger risk indoors
than there is
outdoors so she reiterated that warning
for people to take precautions wash
hands
uh keep two meters distance and so on
from tomorrow face masks are or face
coverings
are mandatory on public transport in
shops and an enclosed spaces she said
make a face covering as automatic is
putting on
a seat belt in a car from the 15th of
july good news for the retail sector and
hospitality
restaurants can now take customers
indoors albeit with appropriate
conditions revised seating arrangements
uh two meters distance ideally
although in the retail hospitality
sector there would be some compromise
on that assuming that precautions were
taken protective screens
and so on uh she said that
scotland was in a position to bring
forward a couple of measures that had
been some distance into the future that
relates to
places of worship people can now return
to communal prayer albeit at a distance
inside of
two meters there will still be
restrictions though on singing
and chanting she also said that when it
comes to funerals weddings
and civil partnerships there would be an
easing
of restriction on numbers who could
attend
those only at the services not at the
wake
or at the after party so generally
a substantial easing of restrictions as
i say she called it the most significant
easing so far but there was a reminder
in there that the virus could come back
that was a real risk and there was a
real priority to contain it
particularly with a view to any return
of covert 19 over the winter months
and there were some encouraging uh
figures in terms of the prevalence of
the virus north of the border
uh adam you mentioned only three people
in intensive care she made the point
that it was only recently
that claustrophobia made the point that
it was recently that 20 people
uh there was an average of 20 cases a
day
in scotland that has now reduced to
seven
three weeks ago she said 2 900 people
were infected
in scotland yesterday that figure was a
thousand